it's official roughly two months after
valorent pro
j sinatra wan was accused of sexual
assault and sexual misconduct by an
ex-girlfriend
developer riot games has handed the
sentinels player a six-month competitive
ban
riot games also stated it had quote
serious concerns regarding his conduct
during its investigation
and that he would need to complete quote
professional conduct training
prior to his return
on monday may 17th riot games published
a statement regarding the status of
sentinel's valorant player sinatra
quote jay sinatra juan has violated rule
8.1 of the ballarant global competition
policy
for failing to fully cooperate with the
tournament operator's investigation
and will be suspended for six months he
will also be required to complete
professional conduct training
end quote now rule 8.1 of valoran's
global competition policy
reads as follows quote by agreeing to
this global policy
each team member agrees to cooperate
with the tournament operator in any
internal or external investigation
that the tournament operator conducts
relating to a suspected violation of
this global policy
the applicable event-specific rules or
applicable law
end quote what's important to note here
is that this statement and ruling
does not find sinatra innocent or guilty
of the sexual assault and sexual
misconduct allegations that he was
accused of back in march
furthermore riot stated that when it
comes to these allegations they'd be
deferring to law enforcement
or waiting for quote additional material
information
to come to light the suspension stems
specifically from the fact that
according to
riot sinatra did not fully cooperate
with them during its investigation
into these allegations despite publicly
stating that he would do so
quote while the investigation did not
come to a definitive conclusion on the
underlying allegations
the competitive operations team had
serious concerns with sinatra's conduct
during the course of the investigation
it was determined that
on at least two occasions sinatra
misrepresented certain facts
made false statements and did not
cooperate with the investigation
in a way expected of a professional
ballerin esports player
of note sinatra's public commitment on
social media to provide the full
audio and video clip referenced in the
original post
was never fulfilled cooperation in these
investigations is of the utmost
importance
especially when the nature of the
allegations is as serious as sexual
assault
this behavior will not be tolerated by
valor and esports
end quote let's talk about the audio and
video clip riot is referring to
and therefore the sexual assault and
sexual misconduct allegations he was
accused of
back in march back on march 9th
sinatra's ex-girlfriend cleo hernandez
published a thorough nine page document
accusing sinatra of sexual assault
and sexual misconduct as part of that
document hernandez included an audio
clip and subsequent transcript of a
situation
where sinatra allegedly forced her to
continue having sex with him
despite stating repeatedly that she
didn't want to we covered this situation
back on this show when the document was
published
she alleges that over the course of that
time he made unwanted sexual advances
after she told him not to she felt like
saying no to sex was
never an option he would continue to
have sex with her after she told him to
stop and was in pain
he acted manipulatively and guilted her
into having sex
after she said no he was emotionally
abusive he would check her location
using his iphone
and if it didn't match where she said
she was he would accuse her of cheating
and that she lived in constant fear of
him a short time later sinatra published
his own statement denying ever
assaulting cleo
and saying that he would cooperate fully
with the investigation
quote i am fully cooperating with the
investigations and providing the full
audio and video clips clio referenced in
her post
end quote sentinels responded by
suspending him
pending the conclusion of riot's
investigation here's sentinel's
statement
quote we are aware of the current
situation regarding j sinatra 1
and have launched an investigation
internally while the investigation is
pending
he is suspended from the team we will
provide a
further update once the investigation
has concluded end quote
so coming back to riot's statement
according to them he did not provide the
full audio and video clips
like he said he would in his original
statement furthermore
whatever facts sinatra allegedly
misrepresented
and false statements he made to riot
during its investigation
none of that has been made public at the
moment it should also be noted that it's
unclear whether or not
riot's investigation is closed as
they've stated that these allegations
are being investigated by
law enforcement and riot will be
deferring to them
quote during the course of the fact
gathering the competitive operations
team
was informed that the matter had been
referred to law enforcement
so at this juncture we will defer to the
authorities to make further
investigation into and factual findings
related to the allegations
end quote now we first learned about law
enforcement's involvement when cleo
published a subsequent document on
tuesday april 20th
expanding on her original allegations
and confirming the existence of a police
report
and ongoing legal investigation i
reached out to washington dc police at
the time hoping to acquire a copy of
that police report
based on the information available they
found one police report filed by someone
named cleo hernandez on march 12th
of this year i was unable to obtain any
further information due to the fact that
the investigation is still ongoing
and because the alleged incident took
place in another jurisdiction
not dc now here's what riot does say
regarding its potentially still
ongoing investigation quote to the
extent that additional material
information comes to light
from law enforcement or otherwise the
competitive operations team reserves the
right to reopen the investigation
and take further appropriate action end
quote now we're not 100
sure that riot's investigation is
definitively closed
but that last statement i just read you
implies
to me anyway that riot's investigation
seems to be closed
unless the law enforcement investigation
provides
new information that would cause riot to
re-open their initial investigation
now according to riot sinatra's
suspension began on march 10th
and therefore will run until september
10 2021
making him technically eligible to
compete for the last chance qualifiers
and champions shortly after riot
published its statement sinatra released
his own twitlonger
here's the opening paragraph of that
quote i've spent the last two months
reflecting on how i can be better as a
person i've been a pro player for
basically all of my adult life
and still have a lot to improve on i've
been reflecting a ton during the down
time
and know how much i hurt cleo
emotionally and i'm truly sorry about it
i will learn from my mistakes
and keep on trying to improve myself as
a person end quote
from there he addressed riot's statement
and said that he never had the audio or
video clips in question
that he deleted them after he and cleo
broke up which he
says was done at her request i want to
preface this by saying i do not have the
video or audio that she used in her
statement
after our relationship ended she asked
me to delete the video and i honored
that
i never even imagined a situation like
this so when it all happened
i didn't know whether to just spill out
my side or not i had no clue what to do
so i seeked legal help immediately as we
were drafting up an
update with the legal pr team we had
added that i would provide the video
because we genuinely thought that the
video would have to be shared in full
since it's a key part in the
investigation end quote
from there he apologized again and said
that he'll use the next four months to
develop quote
a better set of interpersonal skills and
to earn back the trust of this community
end quote roughly 24 hours after sinatra
published his twitlonger responding to
riot games's statement
cleo hernandez who you'll remember is
sinatra's ex-girlfriend that accused him
responded to his twit longer with her
own twitter
in it she says that she never asked him
to delete the audio or video clips
and that she says she would have
welcomed him sharing that with riot's
investigation
quote i'll start by saying that i never
once told him to delete the video
i did not care whatsoever if he kept it
or not i thought he still had it and i
told the riot investigators that i
welcomed him showing the video
because in it you can see his fingers
dig into me when i try and move away
from him
he took the video and he sent it to me
it was just in our text thread because i
never delete text
from there cleo says that she would have
provided the full audio and video clips
if she was requested to but according to
her she never was
on top of that she says that she will
never accept his apology
and that the legal investigation has
been a long process
one that's been quite traumatic for her
to go through quote
so yes he refused to comply with the
investigation was caught in multiple
lies and didn't give a video that
wouldn't have proved his innocence
he gave an apology that i will never at
any point in my life be accepting of
because it is entirely too late the
legal aspect will develop slowly and
depends entirely on my emotional
strength when it comes to dealing with
law enforcement and detectives
which has so far been one of the most
traumatizing things i've ever done
in my life end quote from there cleo
ends the twitlonger basically saying
that at this point she wants to move on
and not have to keep putting out
statements like this what's still
unknown at this point is how
sentinels the org he still technically
signed to
will respond they haven't posted any
statement to social media
and i reached out to them for comment
but didn't hear back in time for
publication
it also raises questions about tenza's
tenure with the org he's been filling in
for sinatra since he was originally
suspended
in that time tens has helped sentinels
win both masters 1
and challenger finals he will also be
competing with the org
at the upcoming masters ii lan in
iceland beginning on may 25th
i also emailed riot in the hopes that
they would clarify the statement that
they published
but i didn't hear back in time for
publication
[Music]
you